I'm Lila I'm John I'm Cassandra
and today we're going to be judging
whether adults are cool or not never do
that
I agree I can do better I
my name is Joanne
what is your favorite Starbucks drink if
you go to school I like the passion
Tango lemonade okay
okay what are your hobbies I like to
dance can you show us your best dance
moves yeah
no music oh my gosh no music
I don't know no music
[Applause]
thank you guys you're really pretty
thank you uh I didn't get all cools but
that's okay I'm so cool in my own heart
my name is Alexa I am excited I'm a
little bit worried I just can't imagine
the situation where they're like I
really approve how many followers do you
have on Instagram I don't have an
Instagram
social medias
I don't have any social media
okay okay
your shoes are kind of beat
um I I don't like beat shoes
don't mind your outfit so yeah I don't I
don't like my new outfit like the shoes
are a little beat up but like a little
I actually need something oh my gosh oh
my God
I was only thinking about appearance I
I'm cool with myself I was initially
excited to do this because I'm raising a
middle schooler and so for me I'm going
to test some material out I want to see
uh if maybe some of the stuff's going to
work on my daughters do you have kids
yeah you're like you're like the cool
dad that's what you are what are you
saying that you're not a cool dad I
couldn't tell you if I'm a cool dad or
not because if you ask my daughter she'd
be like no
all right I've gotta I'll do some dad
jokes this is the worst
all right
knock knock who's there Britney Spears
Britney Spears who knock knock who's
there oops I Did It Again
did that did that work
I love you you are amazing amazing thank
you um
but he's amazing you're funny thank you
I
now you're making me the middle school
boys could never
you are an amazing person yeah you'd be
like the best dad thank you
you're saying he's not cool
how dare you honestly I don't know
you're like a really nice person but I
feel like you're kind of like
embarrassed I could do some more work
right yeah I think it went great I mean
these kids are fun they really wanted to
to kind of intimidate everybody and I
think they recognized that they were
wielding a lot of power they you know
what they all said I was nice and and
for me that was that was pretty good do
I just put it anyway
I think they might think I'm trying too
hard like I really thought about this
outfit I'm not gonna tell them that I'm
only telling you guys that
what's your name my name is b e a where
did you get the jacket from um so I made
this jacket oh my gosh like you
collected all the patches yeah well kind
of I bought a vintage lot of patches on
eBay and then some of them were my dad
like my dad volunteered at this um fire
station in college I am in love with
your jacket I think it's so cool how you
like made it yourself
jacket is fire yeah I like I like your
personality and you're also very pretty
oh thank you
that's so cool thank you guys oh my God
cools across the board which I was kind
of surprised by but they really weren't
as ruthless as I thought they were going
to be I'm scared but I feel like it
could be humbling you know and maybe
it's time to hear some hard truths
what's your name my name's Lizzy I like
to read books I'm sorry you just read it
reading books are just kind of boring
like you don't like doing anything else
I like skiing like winter skiing and
water skiing okay so then like why read
books yeah I agree I can do better so so
Friday night you know you don't want to
be a party pooper so you're like you
know what let me get on the Dance Floor
what are you gonna start doing just like
a little bit of those
whoa whoa oh okay oh that hurt my knees
okay at least you did it yeah
never do that again in your whole entire
life no no never not once
sorry I dropped it
I came out of there alive with a cool
rating and boy did they get me I I
probably can't ever handle something
like that again
you know I'm really not a kids person
Middle School boys my worst nightmare I
think I'll get three cools but
realistically
oh yeah your hair is cute thanks wow I
like the nose nose ring if you lived in
Rhode Island no I just have this shirt
so um what are some of your hobbies
um I like to eat food I like to travel I
like to watch TV
okay
um I think that's all I do damn that's
kind of sad
Prime Netflix Hulu peacock or Paramount
oh I might go Prime no Hulu Hulu what do
you like to do like during your free
time
um
like go home and lay in my bed and watch
TV nothing else no Netflix and chill
like there's no one to chill with I
don't know
are you crying
oh no I'm good I'm good hit on my uh
childhood Trauma from Mom you know she
just wants me to oh my God be dating you
know I forgot
[Applause]
oh
I got three knuckles
one second oh
a lot of judgments a lot of immediate
judgments I don't think they like me and
I don't think I like them
I'm a little nervous middle schoolers
are kind of terrifying nice to meet you
hi what's your name my name is Skyler
you look like you're into zodiac signs I
am do you like crystals I'm not a
crystal person what do you like to do
for fun I usually like reading
foreign
you have great energy and I just think
you're like such a nice person and very
positive um I I think you're a very nice
person very cool but um books
[Music]
I sneeze sometimes
you know what two out of three I'll take
you I got two out of three
the only reason I didn't get the third
cool was because I liked books and I
know my kids they've got other things to
worry about like that's fine this was
very like
of validating and I can go and tell my
friends to middle schoolers think I'm
cool
or not cool
[Music]